[MUSIC PLAYING]
BRAD ABRAMS: Now, we're at the
end-to-end tour of the Google
Cloud Platform.
You've gotten all settled.
And you're ready to go.
We thought, in order
to give you this tour,
we'd build out a
real application.
We're going to extend
that meme app, Cloud meme
application that we
saw in the keynote.
And we're going to show you some
real business logic, written
in App Engine and having
that run on the server.
And we're going to build
that application in just 50
minutes that we have left here.
So I think that's
going to be great.
Don't you think--
BRYAN LYNCH: Wait.
Brad, let's build something
a little more real world.
I meme, you're just talk
about an App Engine app.
I meme, it's a meme.
We're going to have to
store these memes somewhere.
So what about that?
BRAD ABRAMS: I think we may
have time if we push it.
We may have time to
also store the images.
Let's store that in the
Cloud Storage Bucket.
OK.
So I think we can get
these two things done.
BRYAN LYNCH: Wait.
Wait.
Hold on.
We've got to store the
metadata somewhere.
You're going to have metadata.
You're going to have user info.
You're going to
have voting maybe.
You're-- things
associated with the meme.
BRAD ABRAMS: Yeah.
BRYAN LYNCH: We are
we going to put that?
BRAD ABRAMS: I don't know.
What data stores
do you guys use?
What's popular?
No?
No one's volunteering.
What's popular with you?
BRYAN LYNCH: Well, look, Brad.
I think we should go
open source with this.
I'll be honest.
BRAD ABRAMS: Open source?
OK.
BRYAN LYNCH: I think I've
been using Mongo lately.
And I think it's
a good-- I think
it's a good option for us.
BRAD ABRAMS: MongoDB users?
Any MongoDB in here?
Yes.
A couple.
Fantastic.
Fine.
I think probably we could
get a few of the records,
some metadata stored in MongoDB,
running on a GCE Instance.
But now, we really--
we just got to get
started on this now if we're
going to finish this thing.
BRYAN LYNCH: Wait, wait, wait.
Slow down, Brad.
We've got to get a-- this
has got to be real world.
People are using their
mobile phones more and more.
Let's face it.
All the time.
BRAD ABRAMS: Mobile.
BRYAN LYNCH: And
frankly, they're
going to expect some
kind of mobile interface.
BRAD ABRAMS: Awesome.
Well, I guess he's
running the demo.
We got to do it.
So we'll expose this as
a set of REST endpoints.
And then, consume it as
an Android application,
so that you can view and create
those memes on the client.
So what we end up with is a very
basic cloud meme application,
running on the phone.
Lets you view the memes, unless
you go and create a new ones.
BRYAN LYNCH: So I'm going to
start where everyone starts
for Google products.
cloud.google.com.
And I'll go to the
App Engine page first.
And from there, we'll
go ahead and try it now.
BRAD ABRAMS: So you go ahead
and give that any name you want.
Use your creative
freedom there, Bryan.
So we're just
titling this project,
our cloud meme back in.
And then, Bryan's
going to get to select
whatever language he wants.
I'm a Java fan myself.
BRYAN LYNCH: I
have to be honest.
I'm a fan of the
Python right now.
BRAD ABRAMS: Python--
BRYAN LYNCH: I think you
should really go with Python.
BRAD ABRAMS:
[INAUDIBLE] Come on.
It'll never catch on.
But I guess you
got keyboards so--
BRYAN LYNCH: Well, look, Brad.
We can even try it now.
BRAD ABRAMS: Well, that's great.
So you can interact
with this sample
right here in the browser.
There's several for some
popular Python frameworks.
You can go make
a change and then
run it right here
in the browser.
And you can see your
live changes come up.
So this helps people that are
maybe new to the platform.
Help people who are new to
the platform get started.
BRYAN LYNCH: Absolutely.
And look, the next step
we're going to have to do
is install our G Cloud.
BRAD ABRAMS: Yeah.
So now, we're going to
provision Bryan's machine
here with the latest
version of G Cloud.
We have a cURL-based install.
So it's very easy
to get up and going.
And I think Bryan's
already got this installed.
BRYAN LYNCH: I think I'll
just leave the one I have.
BRAD ABRAMS: Maybe we'll
just skip the install step.
BRYAN LYNCH: Oh.
BRAD ABRAMS: Or not.
BRYAN LYNCH: Or not.
No, no.
We'll do it.
BRAD ABRAMS: Apparently,
we'll go through the install.
You can see it's asking Bryan
what languages he wants.
So we can only bring down the
components that really matter.
And then we're bringing
them down onto his machine
and installing those.
And you can see the set of
components that we have here.
So we now have a single
unified installer
for all the components that are
in the Google Cloud Platform.
So you can get up and
running very quickly.
What do you think?
BRYAN LYNCH: And
we'll get there, yeah?
BRAD ABRAMS: We'll get
there in just a minute.
As soon as-- yeah.
So yes.
So how are you enjoying
the day so far?
[LAUGHTER]
Yeah.
So we're done now.
BRYAN LYNCH: There we go.
BRAD ABRAMS: OK.
Great.
So Bryan's just going to
update a few install steps.
OK.
Now, we have G Cloud installed.
So you probably
saw in the keynote,
but we can do a little
playing with G Cloud.
So it's got some
tab completion here.
BRYAN LYNCH: All right.
So I'll do G Cloud.
And I'll hit tab a couple times.
And see what my options are.
Well, let's look
at the components.
So I'll type that.
Double tab it.
And I can complete
my components.
And I'll see what the
options are for that.
And as we saw in
the keynote, you
can actually list what
components you have installed
and what's available.
All right.
BRAD ABRAMS: All right.
Yeah.
So I think we're ready to
initialize this project,
aren't we?
BRYAN LYNCH: Well, Brad, I think
we need to authorize first.
BRAD ABRAMS: Authorization.
Yes.
So how hard is it to log in
and give your credentials
and whatnot.
BRYAN LYNCH: Well.
BRAD ABRAMS: Yeah.
So--
BRYAN LYNCH: If you
spell it right, it helps.
BRAD ABRAMS: So what
Bryan's going to do
is actually use OAuth now
to go and authenticate
so that this instance of the
SDK knows who he is on Google.
So he can access all
his Google accounts
and whatnot for
the Cloud platform.
OK.
So now, I think we're
ready to initialize.
So--
BRYAN LYNCH: We are.
BRAD ABRAMS: --we're
going to do a G Cloud init
and use the project ID
that Bryan created earlier.
And this is a brand
new project, so there's
no code in the repository.
But if there were, it
would sink that down.
Either way, it's setting
up his local instance.
OK.
So I guess we're ready to get
started writing some code.
BRYAN LYNCH: We are.
BRAD ABRAMS: So you have some--
I guess the first step here
is we're going to create a
couple of REST endpoints.
We're going to create one
to list those meme templates
that we have to
base the memes on.
One to create a new meme,
to upload a new meme and one
to list all the finished memes.
BRYAN LYNCH: So look, Brad.
I think we need to start
with writing those endpoints.
So I'll drag over a file
that I set up ahead of time.
BRAD ABRAMS: Yeah.
Julia Child style.
I like it.
BRYAN LYNCH: I go
and open that up.
And as you can see
at the top there,
we've got our
standard endpoints,
imports for endpoints.
Then, we set up our client
IDs for who can access it.
And then, you see
a couple classes
that we've got to wrap
messages between the endpoints
and the mobile client.
So we've got one for memes.
And we're storing the standard
metadata, the image URL,
the text, an ID
to track it later,
a user, and then a votes.
And then, we've also got a class
to wrap that as a collection.
And that's meme collection.
And if we keep scrolling
down that file,
we see a standard
endpoints definition.
So we're defining our API.
We've got cloud meme.
We got a version, a description,
and then the allowed clients.
So basically, you're locking
it down to our mobile client.
And so we can walk
through X from there
into a couple functions we
created on our endpoint,
namely the first one create.
We're going to expect to
be able to create memes
on this service.
BRAD ABRAMS: And notice
this is an HTTP post.
And you'll see in a minute.
You can just use cURL
to be able access these.
So these are standard
REST interfaces.
BRYAN LYNCH: And as you
can see, we've stub it out.
So we'll give it a response
for our early testing.
And the next one we
can look at is listing.
You're going to expect to list
memes once you've put them up.
So we've got there.
And you'll notice
this one's a GET.
So you could do a standard GET
just to get a list of your meme
and returning
stored set of memes.
BRAD ABRAMS: All right.
Yeah.
That looks pretty good.
I think we're-- we basically
have the first part of the demo
ready.
Are we ready to just go
ahead and push that up?
BRYAN LYNCH: Well, let's
go ahead and add it
into our local repository first.
BRAD ABRAMS: Of course.
BRYAN LYNCH: And commit that.
BRAD ABRAMS: So we're
just committing it
to the local repository
on Bryan's laptop.
So now we're ready push it up.
BRYAN LYNCH: Look, Brad.
I think we need to put
some unit tests in.
BRAD ABRAMS: Unit-- you're
such a Google engineer,
doing testing all the time.
So I guess you already have
those ready, prepared as well.
BRYAN LYNCH: Let's say I have
a few that I added in there.
BRAD ABRAMS: All right.
So we have some basic endpoints.
And we have some tests
written for those endpoints.
BRYAN LYNCH: And, look, Brad.
We're going to need
one more thing.
If you want to make
this an App Engine app--
BRAD ABRAMS: We should
make it an App Engine app.
We should make it an
App Engine app as well.
BRYAN LYNCH: So I'll
go drag that in.
And we take a quick look at it.
And those with App
Engine, you can see we've
set up our application.
We've got a version, a runtime
through the settings in there.
And then, our handlers,
we've set up our endpoints.
Handler.
BRAD ABRAMS: All right.
BRYAN LYNCH: So.
BRAD ABRAMS: So now
Bryan's just going
to commit the app.yaml
file and the test file
to his local repository.
And then, we'll do a git
push and push that up
to the repository that the
developer console has for us
already.
OK?
And so that's going to take
just a minute to push up.
So you want to flip over
to the developer console?
BRYAN LYNCH: Absolutely.
BRAD ABRAMS: So
as we saw earlier,
you go to developer tab there.
Yeah.
So as we so earlier, we have
a free private git repository
that's hosted for
you that you can use.
It's accessible to all
the members of your team.
And then, of course, if
you want to use GitHub,
you can absolutely do that.
And then after the
push has happened
as a post commit
action, we're going
to run our Python unit test.
You saw Bryan add
some unit test.
And the way we're
going to do that is,
we have a virtual
machine spun up.
And it's already
running Jenkins.
And Jenkins is the open
source workflow management
tool that's pretty popular.
And he's got plug-ins
for everything.
One of the plug-ins is
to run Python unit test.
So you want to switch
over and look at that VM?
BRYAN LYNCH: Yeah.
Let's do that.
BRAD ABRAMS: So that
VM has been spun up.
And you can see in
a second probably
the spikes were Bryan has
been practicing this demo.
And what we're doing on
this machine right now,
we've already prepared it
with-- or the cloud platform
prepare it for us with Jenkins.
And then, when we
did that push, it
pulled the code
down onto the VM.
And it started executing
all those unit tests.
So at this point, we can see
the progress on the unit test.
And see how they're going.
BRYAN LYNCH: Absolutely.
BRAD ABRAMS: So if
we switch it-- yep.
And they'll release history.
So we should see an entry
there for the unit test.
Yep.
And you can see the tests have
already done and deployed.
But why don't we go ahead
and look at the test, though?
So these are the
tests results page.
So you can see here the list of
all the tests and the runtime.
Bryan wrote some very efficient
tests there looks like.
BRYAN LYNCH:
Stubbed out for now.
BRAD ABRAMS: Yes.
Yes.
OK.
So there's the test results.
So at this point if there
was a break in your test,
you could use this to
drill in and figure out
what the issue was.
So then, if we go
back to release,
I guess we pushed it
to production now.
So we're ready to test that out.
BRYAN LYNCH: It is deployed.
BRAD ABRAMS: So but what
we-- remember what we built
was a set of REST endpoint.
So how we are going to interact
with those REST endpoints
and test them out to see
if there really working?
BRYAN LYNCH: Well, we
can use the API Explorer.
So as you can see, with
any app that you have,
you can actually type
in, use especially
define URL to give
you the Explorer.
BRAD ABRAMS: Yeah.
So underscore A H is the
magic system-provided URL
space for App Engine.
And then, slash API
gets you into endpoints.
And then, slash
Explorer will bring you
into this view with
your own API set.
BRYAN LYNCH: So as you can see,
this is the API we defined,
Cloud Meme API.
And coming into there,
we have the functions
we defined on each of those.
BRAD ABRAMS: Awesome.
Let's take a look.
BRYAN LYNCH: So we go ahead
and test list, for example.
BRAD ABRAMS: Yeah.
And that's returning the
hard-coded set that we have.
Notice in the first
box there, it's
showing you exactly what
that cURL command would be.
What the HTTP git is to be
able to access this method.
And then, it shows you
the response in JSON.
So this is a nice
debugging tool.
It's a nice way to
establish use bug
something is-- if it's on
the client or on the server.
You know if it works here,
then it's not a server issue.
BRYAN LYNCH: I'm
going to go back.
We could even test our create.
Probably stub that out as well.
And inside the request body,
you can add in the elements
that we expect.
So I'll put in a test URL
as well as some test text.
And I can go ahead and
execute that as well.
BRAD ABRAMS: Oh, it looks like
you've got an error there.
BRYAN LYNCH: We do
need to authenticate.
BRAD ABRAMS: OK.
BRYAN LYNCH: So we are
going to ask our users
to authenticate to create memes.
So you can do that here
by clicking on top,
button at the top
and authorizing.
And then, we can go ahead
and run that same query.
BRAD ABRAMS: Yep.
And notice here in
the request again,
it shows you the
metadata that you
need to send up with the
request to be authenticated.
So again, if you
wanted to try this,
write your own lightweight
wrapper for it.
You could in
JavaScript or whatnot.
And of course, it
shows you the results.
BRYAN LYNCH: Absolutely.
BRAD ABRAMS: OK.
So I think we've got the
first step done, right?
BRYAN LYNCH: We do.
BRAD ABRAMS: OK.
So let's switch
back to the slides.
So what we just showed you
is that it's very easy to get
started.
We talked about using
those standard tools.
We showed you the simple
build, test, and deploy.
And how to test the
service with API explorer.
Obviously, we only
touched on this briefly.
If you want to drill in more
in this room, at 1 o'clock,
they'll be at DevOps at
Google that I encourage
you to come to where we'll
drill into it in more detail.
OK.
We're ready for step two.
So Bryan said we're going
to build an Android app.
So let's jump right into that.
We're going to focus on
two key pieces of that.
One is we're going to build an
Android-optimized Java client
library for the services
that you just saw.
And we're going to
show how to integrate
that with Android Studio.
So back to demo machine.
BRYAN LYNCH: All right.
We're back in our directory
that we had our files in.
And we can run the
endpoints command git here.
We'll get the client
live out of it.
We'll give it Java.
We'll give it our class name.
And then, we'll ask for it to
build-- give us a build system.
And we'll use Maven.
BRAD ABRAMS: So what
this is doing right now
is it's taking the
description of the service,
the generic description
of the service.
And it's creating an
Android-optimized Java client
library for it.
So that as an
Android developer, I
want to interact with classes.
Those entities
should be classes.
And then methods,
the REST method
should actually be methods on
a class on a request factory.
And that's exactly what
you're seeing here.
All the entities Bryan
created earlier in Python,
we now have Java
versions of them.
And then, we have the cloud
memes request as well.
So now what's left to go--
oh, do you want to look at one
of them, or--
BRYAN LYNCH: Well.
BRAD ABRAMS: Yeah.
Bryan, let's look
at one of them.
That's fantastic.
BRYAN LYNCH: So as
you can see, it's
creating basically
a model for your--
to wrap all the communication
between the end point.
And then, if you
come in here, you
can see it's creating
for this one.
We are looking at basically
a cloud meme collection.
And it's just showing
building a collection up
of cloud memes in
standard getter and setter
methods for it.
BRAD ABRAMS: Yep.
So this is going to handle all
the authentication hassles, all
the network plumbing,
all the serialization
and deserialization
to JSON and back.
So really, it makes
this very simple to use.
BRYAN LYNCH: And
so the next step
is going to basically
install our Maven repository.
Install it locally.
BRAD ABRAMS: So because,
in just a minute,
we're going to access
it from Android Studio,
Android Studio
uses Gradle as its
build system which knows how
to speak to the local Maven
repository.
So to make that
easy, we're going
to put it into our local
Maven repository here.
So I think is that-- that
didn't quite work there, Bryan.
BRYAN LYNCH: No, it did not.
Make sure I'm in
the right directory
BRAD ABRAMS: Ah, OK.
Yes.
BRYAN LYNCH: There we go.
All right.
BRAD ABRAMS: OK.
Great.
Yes.
So now, he's got it in his
local Maven repository.
Now, we're going to pop
up Android Studio, right?
BRYAN LYNCH: Absolutely.
BRAD ABRAMS: So Android Studio
is an IntelliJ-based IDE
that we're moving to.
It's a good option if
you're an Android developer.
And what we're going
to do-- actually,
Bryan already created
most of the Android app,
the boring bits of
the Android app.
All the UI, all the user
interaction is already done.
And what we're
going to show now is
how to access the
service that we defined.
So I guess the first
thing you need to do
is change the Gradle build file.
BRYAN LYNCH: Absolutely.
So we'll open that up.
And we'll add in our dependency
on the new cloud main library.
And we can go ahead
and sync that.
BRAD ABRAMS: Yeah.
So again, Android Studio uses
Gradle as its build system.
You might recognize it's a
Groovy-based build language.
And that's really important
for the flexibility
that you need to build when
you're building Android
apps targeting multiple
devices and whatnot.
And what we've done here is
just referenced that library
that we just added to
our Maven repository.
OK.
So we've got the library.
Now, I see you've got
the source code in there.
BRYAN LYNCH: Yeah.
So we'll open up
our meme lister.
We're going to have
to list our memes.
And then, we'll go ahead
and add in some initial code
to access that new library.
BRAD ABRAMS: Yeah.
So now, we're going to show the
code that's actually required
in order to call those methods.
BRYAN LYNCH: So if we walk
through this very quickly,
we can see we're
importing the Android app.
You can see in
front of here, we're
creating our service
that we're going
to use to communicate
to the endpoint.
At this point, we built it.
And then, for
handling the intent,
this is basically communicating
with the UI layer.
We increase our new meme.
And then, we can handle
the creative turn
back from the back in.
BRAD ABRAMS: OK.
So that look pretty good, right?
We're ready to run it?
BRYAN LYNCH: Let's do it.
BRAD ABRAMS: So just
to make it more fun,
we've already got a version of
the app running on this phone.
So can we switch to the phone?
So this is what
the resulting app
looks like going
against those services.
Notice we only have a
couple of those stock memes
that are there.
But we have the basic UI
functionality in place.
We've got the meme there.
And I can say, Hi, boss.
And I can go ahead
and post that.
And it's calling our service.
But of course, the
service is stubbed out.
So when we do the list again,
we get the same static define
ones.
But we have shown that we
can build a basic Android
application.
And that it can call
our services up there
on the server.
So Ray, can we switch
back to slides, please?
OK.
So right, what we
just showed you
was creating this strongly
typed Java client library.
Using the endpoints command, we
talked about the Maven package
management support and how
to build an Android app.
So at the end of the
day today, or at 3:30
today, there will
be a whole talk
just on building cloud
back-ins for Android Apps.
That will be right in here.
So I encourage you go to
that if you want more info.
OK.
We're ready for the next step.
It's time to make this
thing really production.
It's sort of a toy app so far.
We're ready to make it real.
To make it real, we're
going to do two things.
We're going to store
that image data.
We're going to store it
in Google Cloud Storage,
in our blob storage, our
bucket storage there.
And we're going to spin
up on MongoDB cluster
and store the metadata for
those images in that cluster.
OK, Bryan.
Are we ready to roll with that?
OK.
Let's switch back to
Bryan's demo machine.
BRYAN LYNCH: So if we're going
to add in the next service,
we're going to go
back to our files.
And we've prepped a few
more to accomplish this.
The first thing
we'll do is actually
add in our cloud storage
and our image generation.
And if we pop up in
the cloud storage,
take a quick look at that.
You can see we're importing our
cloud storage Python library.
Which, again, is a
Google-provided library.
Setting up a URL for
the memes to be at.
Coming into our
upload method, we
can see where it's
defining a unique ID,
assigning it a file
name that we're
going to upload
to cloud storage.
And in the middle
of the file, we're
creating our cloud
file on cloud storage.
Putting in settings
there for writing a file,
that it's going
to be a PNG image.
And then, it's public readable.
And then, from there,
we're basically
writing out the
binary image that we
passed into this function
into that cloud storage file.
And then, the last step
is actually writing it out
to cloud storage.
BRAD ABRAMS: Yeah.
That looks pretty easy.
So again, what Bryan
showing you here
is code that running
on App Engine.
That's taking the image
and stitching it together,
putting the text on
it, and storing that up
to cloud storage.
So you want to show
it in cloud storage?
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
Show the cloud storage viewer?
BRYAN LYNCH: So if we come
into the developer console
and you're on your application,
you clicked on a cloud storage.
And you get your browser.
And as you can see, we've
set up some buckets for use.
Cloud Meme Bucket is the
one we are writing to.
BRAD ABRAMS: And it's not really
in Spanish, though, is it?
BRYAN LYNCH: It's
not in Spanish.
No.
And as you can
see, we've actually
been doing a bit of testing.
So you've got some
memes in here already.
And again, this is
all-- can be accessed
from your application,
both writing and reading.
BRAD ABRAMS: OK.
So that looks great.
So that's the basic story for
storing memes in cloud storage
store, storing the image
data cloud storage.
The next step we need to
do is store the metadata.
That is, the text description
so we can do searches
on it, who uploaded the
meme, and other metadata.
So in order to do that, we
need to create MongoDB cluster,
don't we?
BRYAN LYNCH: Let's do that.
BRAD ABRAMS: So
we're actually going
to use Cloud Deployment
Manager which
you'll hear about
a little bit later.
But it's a way to
deploy software
onto Compute Engine instances.
And we're going to spin up
several nodes of MongoDB
and configure them
for us to use.
BRYAN LYNCH: Absolutely.
So basically, on this
page, we have a way
to deploy MongoDB
in a size cluster.
So basically, we've
set up a replica name.
You can just choose a zone.
Choose a network
to deploy it to.
Give it a prefix.
And then, actually
choose the count
you want to deploy of nodes.
As well as set up your disk
sizes and your arbitrary.
BRAD ABRAMS: And you can just
hit the deploy cluster there.
That's going to take a
few minutes to deploy.
So we already actually
have a MongoDB cluster
that we deployed earlier.
So we're going to
switch over to use that.
But this is a great
way if you want
to experiment with the
platform, do some performance
testing on it, do some
capability testing.
This is an easy way for you
to go put some open source
packages up there and see
how they perform for you.
And of course, all this is being
deployed on virtual machines
that you own, that you
can go and SSH into,
control, however you want.
So they're fully yours.
BRYAN LYNCH: So the
next thing we'll do
is actually add in the
connector for the Mongo.
So I've got a little code
that I prepped ahead of time.
So we' go ahead and
cut and paste that back
in our API file.
And as you can see,
for the import,
we're inputting our
PYMongo library.
We're setting up our
Mongo connect string.
If you're familiar
with Mongo, you'll
recognize the user, password
IP, and then the database.
BRAD ABRAMS: We've
got to remember
to change that
password after this.
BRYAN LYNCH: We'll definitely
change that password.
And from there, we
can add in actually
first add in our create.
So we've got a
create function here.
So we'll scroll down to create.
And we'll create,
[INAUDIBLE] our create there.
And then, we'll also have
a way to list our memes.
Get the [INAUDIBLE]
back from Mongo.
So we'll going ahead and
take that and paste that in.
Replacing our stubbed
implementation.
And then, we forgot
to do one more thing.
I'll scroll up.
We did forget to put in the
code for our cloud storage
connectors.
So we'll go ahead-- we'll go
ahead and add that in as well.
So we'll add in our
imports for cloud storage.
BRAD ABRAMS: Those are handy
comments you have there.
That's very helpful.
BRYAN LYNCH: And the bucket.
And then, we'll go ahead and add
in the code to create the meme
as well as upload
it to cloud storage.
Back into our create.
And replace our
stubbed implementation.
And now we're ready to
create in the cloud.
BRAD ABRAMS: OK.
So now what we have is
code that can store images
in cloud storage and store
the metadata into MongoDB.
And then, when we
do the listing,
it pulls the image URL
out of cloud storage
and pulls the metadata
our of MongoDB
and returns that back
to the client, all
over REST endpoints.
BRYAN LYNCH: And so to
make this happening,
we've got a few libraries
we need to install as well.
BRAD ABRAMS: OK.
Right.
BRYAN LYNCH: Just
standard libraries.
So we'll drag those all in.
Go back to our console.
Add the stuff we just
committed to the local repo.
Mongo.
BRAD ABRAMS: OK.
So this is going to
take just a minute.
Bryan's going to commit it
to his local repository.
And then, he's going
to do a git push
and deploy it up to
the App Engine app.
Now, what's going to happen
on the App Engine app is,
we're going to sink down all
the source code that he just
created, including his unit
tests onto that Compute Engine
instance.
And then, we're going use
Jenkins to orchestrate
a workflow that has us doing
tests, running all of his unit
tests across those.
And then, when those
unit tests are done,
go ahead and push that
out into production.
Now, all that's going to
take a couple of minutes.
So in the meantime, let's
look at the release history.
And maybe we can look at
the diffs between releases.
BRYAN LYNCH: Absolutely.
BRAD ABRAMS: So one of the
things that is very cool
is that we actually roll
up all the release diffs
into a single view.
So imagine, you have
a production issue,
and you're debugging it.
You want to know what code
changes went in this last time.
So if we do that, we
see this diffu here.
Notice there's two different
changes that went in.
Both done by Bryan.
But in a big project,
you might have
them done by several people.
And then, we can
get a sense for what
changed at this
particular release.
So just click on one of them.
And let's see.
Pick out a more interesting one.
BRYAN LYNCH: OK.
BRAD ABRAMS: Not that one.
Any one but that one.
OK.
Well.
All of them are
starting from blank.
Is that basically the deal?
OK.
Yep.
So anyway it would show you
exactly what the changes are.
So should we go over and
see what our [INAUDIBLE] is?
BRYAN LYNCH: Oh, Brad.
I just realized we did
forget one more thing.
BRAD ABRAMS: Oh, my goodness.
One more thing.
BRYAN LYNCH: We're
in our app demo,
so make sure that we update
this to the latest version.
So I'm going to make a change.
BRAD ABRAMS: Ah, yes.
The demo version.
BRYAN LYNCH: And make sure we
update to the real version.
Yeah.
Called demo one for now.
BRAD ABRAMS: OK.
Yep.
So you're seeing
in the real thing.
So now, we get to
go deploy it again.
And now, what will
happen now is if it's not
done with the build and test
when a new one comes in,
it actually scraps that one and
start over with the new one.
So it doesn't wait for
the first one to finish.
Because we notice this
kind of thing happens,
right last minute you
figure you missed something.
So there's no point in finishing
the build on the other one
if there's a new
one right behind.
BRYAN LYNCH: And so you can
see, we've come to our source.
We see that our
source repository's
already been updated.
And then, right now it's
pushing it out, putting into--
BRAD ABRAMS: Yep.
BRYAN LYNCH: Pushing it into the
Jenkins, doing the unit tests.
BRAD ABRAMS: So you want
to see if we're-- if it's--
BRYAN LYNCH: Let's see if
it has reached the test now.
BRAD ABRAMS: So
the way this works
is this line is actually written
as soon as the unit tests start
to run.
In the case of Python or
in the case of a Java,
as soon as the build starts.
So is it there?
BRYAN LYNCH: It's there.
BRAD ABRAMS: OK.
Great.
Fantastic.
Oh, and it already deployed.
BRYAN LYNCH: It did deploy.
BRAD ABRAMS: Awesome.
So we're ready to test it out.
So you want to test it
out in API Explorer?
BRYAN LYNCH: Absolutely.
All right.
So we can come back
into our API Explorer.
Just refresh.
We see our methods
we had before.
They're no longer stubbed out.
So we'll go ahead
and do our list.
BRAD ABRAMS: And so
this list at this point
is-- we have a great
server error there.
BRYAN LYNCH: Well, look.
I'll make sure we're on
the right version, man.
BRAD ABRAMS: OK.
So what Bryan's
going to do now-- so
App Engine actually
supports having
multiple versions
of your application
running in production
at the same time.
And that's useful for doing
things like A/B testing.
It's useful when you're
staging out a release.
Maybe you want to have it only
accessible to a few people.
And then, roll it out
to be the main version.
BRYAN LYNCH: So we'll go
ahead and do a list on that.
BRAD ABRAMS: And
now, we got them.
And look, those are-- so that's
pulling this metadata directly
out of MongoDB.
So the MongoDB instance
running on GCE,
pulling that data
through to App Engine.
And then, it sends
it out, serializes it
to this JSON interface.
BRYAN LYNCH: And we'll
go ahead and list--
we have a set of templates
that we can build from.
So we'll go ahead
and list those.
BRAD ABRAMS: And you can,
maybe, grab one of those URLs.
BRYAN LYNCH: I'll grab
that top rural there.
BRAD ABRAMS: And then,
my favorite thing.
You can go in and
actually post a new meme.
And this time when
he posts a meme,
it will actually
create that meme,
store the meme in cloud
storage, and store
the metadata in MongoDB.
BRYAN LYNCH: And we
want make sure we
auth before we send that off.
BRAD ABRAMS: Ah, yes.
BRYAN LYNCH: And we'll go
ahead and execute that.
BRAD ABRAMS: Yes.
Fantastic.
OK.
So it looks like it worked.
Did it create the meme?
BRYAN LYNCH: It did
create the meme.
BRAD ABRAMS: So
"What Urs Says Goes."
OK.
So now what we
want to do, can we
switch over to
the mobile device?
And you see, I just
refreshed this right now
as they were coming.
And the very first meme
is the one he created.
"What Urs Says Goes."
So pretty cool, huh?
And of course, I can
do the same thing.
I can say-- oh, whoops.
"Yes boss--" whoops.
And I can go ahead
and post that.
And now, I'm posting it
from the Android device.
It's going up through
the App Engine endpoint,
storing the image in cloud
storage, the metadata
in MongoDB, and then returning
all the results back down
to the device.
So that's pretty neat.
OK.
So are we ready to
switch back to slides?
BRYAN LYNCH: Yes.
BRAD ABRAMS: OK.
So let's go back to slides.
Yes.
So did we do this one?
No, we didn't do this one.
OK.
So what we just showed you
was the cloud storage MongoDB
thing.
I mentioned MongoDB uses
Google Deployment Manager.
And you saw some of the replica
pooled stuff Bryan just touched
on a little bit.
There's a whole session
on that at one o'clock
upstairs that you can go
and drill in and learn more
about that.
And I know some of these
sessions conflict in time.
All this is being preserved
on the internets forever.
So you can go watch these
at your leisure later.
OK.
So that's step three.
But I'm not really
satisfied yet, Bryan.
We got a working application.
But we haven't really
proven to these people
that it can scale, yet.
So I think we should show that.
So we're going to show some
very simple load testing.
And then, we're going
to use that load testing
to isolate an issue
in production.
And then, show you how we can
fix that issue in production
very quickly
OK.
You want to take it away
back to demo machine?
We do?
BRYAN LYNCH: Yeah.
All right.
So we're going to basically
kick off a load test.
And we'll just use ApacheBench
as we used in the keynote.
But for this one, we're going to
throw a little bit more at it.
So I'm going to say,
throw a billion rows.
BRAD ABRAMS: How do you know?
A billion, that's pretty good.
BRYAN LYNCH: Ah, maybe we'll go,
I don't know, 200 concurrent.
And then, we'll give
a URL we can hit.
BRAD ABRAMS: So Bryan defined
a special endpoint for create
that just tests out storing
a particular image to cloud
storage and storing some
metadata to MongoDB.
And so hitting this a million
times, 200 simultaneous,
is going to give us a pretty
decent QPS, queries per second,
or requests per second.
At Google everything is queries.
So we call them
queries per second.
So we're hitting that.
And now we're going back to
the developer console here.
And you can see,
some of the graphs
are starting to notice
the increased load there.
And I notice, Bryan,
these errors by code.
Just scroll down a little bit.
We're starting to see-- or
at least last time you did
the demo, I saw--
BRYAN LYNCH: We do have
a few spikes coming up.
Yeah.
BRAD ABRAMS:--a few spikes.
There's a little
latency in the graph.
So we'll see a spike
in 500s in a minute.
So why don't we switch over
to the data-- the logs viewer,
and see if we can find out why
we're seeing those log errors.
So again, here what we're
seeing is all those requests
are coming in.
And each request from
whatever frontend-- I think we
said we have five or 10
frontends running right now.
There's about five
And we're aggregating logs
from all those frontends
and putting them here.
Every create is
creating a log entry.
And you notice, some of
them are actually 500s.
So you're going to filter down
to find out just those 500s.
So those are troubling.
That means we actually have
an issue in production.
And it seems to be happening
for only some requests.
So we need to debug this and
figure out what's happening.
BRYAN LYNCH: Well, it looks
like there's an exception, Brad.
BRAD ABRAMS: There's
an exception.
BRYAN LYNCH: Let's
track that down.
And we're going to click
down and in the file.
BRAD ABRAMS: Yeah.
So in the keynote, we
showed you that in Java.
And here, we're showing
you it in Python.
So the same basic
infrastructure works no matter
what language you use.
BRYAN LYNCH: And as you can see,
I dropped this into the file
and highlighted the line
that's causing the problem.
BRAD ABRAMS: Yes.
I think that a random 5 is
probably the source your--
BRYAN LYNCH: It looks a
little bit manufactured.
I agree.
BRAD ABRAMS: Its looks a
little bit of an issue.
So again, at this point, because
it's in a git repository,
we could go back to the local
machine and fix this issue.
But because it seems like a
pretty obvious fix, I think,
Bryan's just going click
on Edit here and go ahead
and remove this
erroneous change.
And then, he's going to commit
that back to his production git
repository.
And so you should probably
have this down by now.
What's going to happen
when he clicks commit.
Right?
So it's going to
put that change in
the Google-hosted repository.
And then, it's going to sink
down the code into the Compute
Engine virtual machine that's
running Jenkins on there.
And then, that Jenkins
workflow is going to kick in.
And it's going to run all
our unit tests across there.
And given that those
pass, hopefully, we'll
deploy that out into production.
So that might take
just a minute for it
to deploy out to production.
OK.
So yes.
So what we're showing you here
is that it's already deployed.
It has already
run all our tests.
And it just finished
deploying to production.
So now, if we go back
to the logs viewer,
we should see a
beautiful lack of 500s.
If we're successful here, as
he scrolls down-- remember,
we're still hitting this site
with a billion requests, right?
So it's going to take a
while to get through those.
And now, we don't see any 500s.
So I think our logs are clean.
That's pretty good, Bryan.
BRYAN LYNCH: It looks good.
Yeah.
BRAD ABRAMS: Thanks, man.
That's good.
All right.
Cool.
OK.
So back to the slides.
And then, let's wrap us up here.
So what we showed
you in this part
is some basic load
testing with ApacheBench.
We showed you how to do
some debugging in production
and how to fix that
production issue.
So if you want to hear
more about how some of this
works under the covers, what's
really going on, at 2 o'clock
there'll be a Seeing Inside
Your Service session.
That's a good one
for you check out.
OK.
So, wow.
We did a bunch here, Bryan.
We started absolutely
from scratch.
We built a real world
Android application.
It had MongoDB and Google
Cloud Storage in it.
And then, we showed the
whole DevOps workflow here.
So that's pretty
good for 50 minutes.
Don't you think?
BRYAN LYNCH: Not bad.
No.
BRAD ABRAMS: I
have a hunch there
might be a few people
that want the source
code for what you just did.
And Bryan will post that shortly
up on his GitHub repositories.
So you can go and
check that out.
And then, a lot of
what we've shown
is already available to
you in the Cloud Console.
But there's a few things
that were not quite ready.
So if you want to get
Trusted Tester access,
there's a form you
can fill out there.
All of it will be ready
in the next few weeks.
But if you just
can't wait and you
need the linking logs to source
or some of the other features,
you can fill out this form
and get access to that.
So thank you very much.
BRYAN LYNCH: Thank you.
BRAD ABRAMS: And now, we have
a couple minutes for questions,
I think.
So any questions for us?
Anyone?
Yes.
Right here.
AUDIENCE: The
testing that you just
showed, do you support A/B
testing and staged roll-outs?
BRAD ABRAMS: Yes.
So the question was about A/B
testing and staged roll-outs.
So we don't have any built in
support for that right now.
But it's absolutely something
that's on our road map
to go do.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: How does the
Cloud Endpoints on Android
compare in performance against
just using [INAUDIBLE]?
BRAD ABRAMS: Yeah.
So the question
was in performance
between Cloud
Endpoints on Android
and just an HTTP library.
I think you'll find they're are
very similar because you saw
the REST requests
that we were showing.
You can hit those with cURL.
There's very little
extra metadata
that we're sending down
for Cloud Endpoints.
So I suggest you go
do some perf testing.
But it should be pretty close.
OK.
Oh, and there's a mic.
Fantastic.
AUDIENCE: So let me-- Hello?
Hello?
BRAD ABRAMS: I can repeat.
I can repeat.
Go ahead.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
BRAD ABRAMS: Yeah.
BRAD ABRAMS: Yes.
BRYAN LYNCH: So it's
something we're looking at.
Today, we're looking
at purely a launch.
Once you get it launched,
you can manage it yourself.
But ongoing, we'll look
at additional tools
we can provide.
BRAD ABRAMS: Yeah.
But Bryan, when we
were building his demo,
very regularly went
to the Mong-- in fact,
can you bring it up?
Can you up the
Mongo admin console?
BRYAN LYNCH: Absolutely.
BRAD ABRAMS: So
it's just installing
Mongo on a GCE image.
So all the existing
MongoDB admin tools work.
So we haven't done
anything special.
What Bryan's mentioning, we have
integrated the MongoDB admin UI
into our developer console.
But you can just
hit the right URLs.
Right?
BRYAN LYNCH: Uh, no.
BRAD ABRAMS: Not yet.
BRYAN LYNCH: Well, not yet.
Not yet.
BRAD ABRAMS: Soon.
Soon.
BRYAN LYNCH: Something
we're working on.
BRAD ABRAMS: Soon.
OK.
Coming soon.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Any planned
languages coming up?
BRAD ABRAMS: Planned languages?
So there is a session.
AUDIENCE: Like Ruby
or [INAUDIBLE]?
BRAD ABRAMS: There is a
session called something
like new languages in App Engine
that I encourage you to go to.
OK.
So I think we're just
about out of time.
This is the only thing
separating you from lunch.
So Bryan and I will be up
here for a few more minutes.
So feel free to come grab us
if you have more questions.
Thank you.
BRYAN LYNCH: Thank you.